oh wow um there's a lack of real
anything happening supposed to be a pit
we're down there it's a little hard to
tell I'll just take your word for it
[Applause]
hey welcome back to another episode of
potato mode again where we take the most
beautiful games we know and turn them
into absolute mush I am Joey I'm joined
by jean-luc here hello and we are gonna
play some Dark Souls remastered game was
remastered and re-released just last
week I think
mm-hmm and I don't know I haven't played
too much of it but uh gentle God when
you take it away tell me how it looks it
looks pretty good it's not as big as say
something like a shout out the Colossus
but they've improved the lighting
heavily they the fire effects are
significantly better than they were that
was also perfect timing thank you this
is probably the worst game to try and do
like a potato mode on oh no I think it's
the best game I mean it probably is but
like trying to play this also at the top
of sense fortress this is my save right
now this is a terrible place to be so is
there a good Vista here I think that
that's one thing that we always try to
look for on the show is just good vistas
to appreciate the graphics if I had
gotten to the end of this area it was
actually a really good one let me try
and see if I can head just somewhere
else I'm good I'm gonna attempt to go
back back down since worthless which is
what you're not supposed to do by the
way beautiful vistas away Joey nice
where'd you like to go we got a very
dark garden we've got a beautiful undead
village we have a very very dark
rickety blight town hmm which of the
three dark dead places would I like to
visit you said the last one was a blight
town light town Blighttown it's infamous
I think let's go bleh all right we're
gonna buy town oh god blight on the
worst worst area in the game boy what
it's everyone's least favorite it
doesn't seem that bad it's pretty bad in
the original version of the game it ran
at a sub ten frames a second you say ten
ten ten ten god Joey I can't believe you
made me go for science okay science
alright anyway we're here Blighttown
we've saved it's uh it's a disgusting
swamp Joey let's make it look worse so
we got the resolution the refresh rate
display mode whether you want it full
screen or window vsync and then here
you're for quality options so there's
not a whole lot that you can do with it
now um but we can try all right so here
we go alright everything's stretched its
so how blue we're looking so so this
kind of brings us back to the the
original version we've kind of D
mastered the remaster almost a little
bit the fire is still pretty nice I
think there's a little some complaints
around this tree master but for the most
part I would say they've done a good job
bringing this up to snuff for modern
systems modern pcs it runs smooth you
don't have to install a third-party mod
to get it looking good on PC yeah that's
always good but you probably have some
third-party mods of your own oh yeah I
have plenty let's go and so the profile
inspector once again it does a whole lot
of weird crap to the the textures in the
game which is funny enough the main
thing that they probably changed in Dark
Souls remastered it's like I haven't I
have not tested it fully at the highest
settings or I mean at the the maximum
potato quality but yeah they were doing
it in the good old I can't see the the
text anymore okay we don't need to see
it text oh look at that so just think
the lack of texture it's a little bit
smoother a little smoother
hello there oh that's the fire effects I
remember from the original King I mean
in in the game's defense lots of the
enemies are just giant massive blobs of
scary crap anyway right yeah it's
actually easier to see stuff a little
bit is because it's getting rid of like
them
is there like mist or something yeah or
just like all the shading and it'll be
like let's go to a place with a lot of
fire we're gonna head to lost izalith
which funny enough is actually one of
the later areas in the game in an area
that was rushed for time so it actually
already had sort of an unfinished look
to it Oh God
again this area was already kind of
looking a little unfinished it's just a
lot of open space this guy gave a couple
of little arches there here and there
the texture doesn't look as bad like
it's not like a lot missing yeah thanks
very much I think because this is
probably unfinished it's gonna require a
little bit more work on our end yeah oh
my god I actually love the way this
looks it's look better okay so this is
sort of a unique boss you're actually
supposed to you can find them
traditionally or you can turn it into
like a kind of scripted sequence mm-hmm
where you can like trick him into like
falling off it's woo or he does that no
I remember I do I don't remember to do
this okay
the lake it is awesome I'm still very
impressed that you can navigate the
mainland so effortlessly you just kind
of get used to it can you park yourself
in front of the wall real quick this is
a goal good old potato moodface right
here the thing is the faces and
darksouls looks so bad it actually
doesn't look that yeah yeah I was about
to say he looks not bad you kind of cute
actually just kind of with the beady
eyes and just sitting there with this
innocent looking face oh wow um there's
a lack of real anything happening a pit
we're down there that's a pit it's a
little hard to tell I'll just take your
word for it
oh what's France look like now what is
this oh my god this is one of the little
tiny messages that appear on the ground
yes you know except it's huge
there's normally trees here the trees
are gone Joey hold on run I need to kill
these guys
a little bit of groundskeeping I'm sure
but all these trees are gone
yeah member well there were a bunch of
trees here remember beautiful vistas
away Joey I'm having a hard time
remembering but I'll take your word for
it I might turn it on just for my own
sake looks like oh my god
wait where's his hair in his head what
happened to him with he's got like a
long head of hair and a beard oh my god
that's that's okay
clearly he has hair in here oh my god
what what does he have clothing it is
all flesh colors that flesh colored
clothing so we get around to the back of
his head what's the OS at work we're
stopping this right now no we have to
keep going Oh yep I'm already seeing a
lack of they're supposed to be trees
here trunks a little Charlie Brown tree
right there all the leaves are gone also
this well this area would lead to the
DLC but I don't think I've unlocked a
party so I'm really really liking these
water ripples he's like octagonal oh
yeah that's great
oh this is my favorite part is this area
he's like all the stuff that should be
here that's not and I love it how do you
want to quickly do a new character yeah
let's do that let's do that then kind of
I kind of want to go with that hat I
think I look pretty cool yeah let's go
that let's give me flashbacks of the
doom episode colors and like I don't
know the way that the the textures look
on like skulls especially like a whole
mountain range over here you can kind of
see it you can also see the horizon the
back I really I would love to see a game
that actually kind of leans into this
art style yeah like I want a potato mode
game Jam where everyone has to make a
game that looks like the aesthetic of a
potato mode episode oh man that would be
good
victory achieve
well I think that was a very successful
run for us yes the potato mode if you'd
like to see more potato mode make sure
to follow us on youtube and we also have
an on site as well mm-hmm
and if you have a game that you'd like
to see potato fide you can always leave
it in the comments below or tweet at us
we'll be sure to add it to our growing
list of suggestions and oh by the way
starting this week we have potato mowed
shirts yes might as well just promote
those as well I ordered one it should be
arriving in a day or two sweet I haven't
gotten one yet so I will maybe get one
at some point getting more for free
right like do you have to pay for that I
don't know I'm gonna have to talk to
someone if not but anyways we'll just
watch this ending cutscene and we will
see you guys next time on potato house
bad the camera so demanding